All right, so how was everybody doing? We are going to share my desktop and
you'll be able to see it right now. All right, so if anybody has questions, pop in and ask them.
And if you, if I have to meet you guys, make sure you just text them on your screen through this question.
So before we get to too many questions, we're going to talk about some new information.
What's called a topology, and we're going to go over this slide right here, which is a bunch of information that looks very messy.
But hopefully we'll start explaining it and we're going to go over a topology and how it relates to cancer as a topic, at least a side topic of the next several of the zoom calls, because this is going to relate to every single person's cancer.
So first, let's define some terms. The topology is how, as a cell goes through apoptosis, how that cell is recycled and when a person has cancer, a topogy, an apoptotic pathways become blocked.
So that's what we want to look at is where are those pathways blocked? What could slow down a topology in apoptosis? What can block it and what could speed up cell replication?
So I am going to hit play on this so you can see it. Can you still see my screen?
Yes. Okay. So then you get a bigger picture, but this is the main picture that we're going to go through here over the next multiple weeks because there's a lot on this picture, right?
So this is just one gene that we look at when I look at your 23 and me, this mTOR gene. This mTOR gene has a family of genes. There's multiple mTOR genes. They all do the same thing. What they do is they help you heal. So they're very important.
So it's really important to understand that when we talk about any pathway in your body, it's easy to think of them as good guys and ad guys, but it's really not true. It's about balance.
So it was a person has cancer. We don't want cells replicating, right? But that's actually how cells heal. So if I cut my arm, the only way that that cell heals is through stimulation of a pathway and how that heals is stimulation of the mTOR pathway here.
So it actually stimulates it partly through this and biggest way with an injury is through
insulin growth factor one, this where I circle, if you can see by cursor. So your brain stimulates. This shows dairy stimulating insulin growth factor one, but in a wood healing, your brain through the hypothalamus pathway stimulates insulin growth factor one to stimulate the mTOR pathway.
To stimulate R&A translation or replication and protein synthesis healing membranes, et cetera. So normally by my tissue of my hand will only replicate itself about once every 12 weeks.
But in the case of an injury, now it's replicating multiple times a minute in order to heal that wood.
And that is that wood is healed and scar tissue fills that wood that that pathway shuts down. And now I have a wood there that I take time to heal, but that's how your body will heal.
So what happens with kids are as you get stuck in that pathway turned on. So you get stuck with an mTOR pathway turned on, or you're blocking the topogy and a poptonic pathway. And that's that's what we want to look at.
So there's some issues with with this and we're as we talk through this. I think the more we talk through it, the more you'll understand that these can these are can be life saving processes like in the case of a wood healing, it's a life saving process.
We have insulin growth factors secreted in mTOR op regulation. The wood won't heal, but I believe that.
So it's an important thing. And this is what I've spoken about in other other lectures and that should I have the surgery to remove the tumor.
Well, there's good and bad to that. If I have the surgery to remove the tumor, I will debulk the tumor, but the very fact that I have surgery is going to highly up regulate insulin growth factor, which is a growth hormone, which is going to stimulate mTOR, which is going to stimulate replication.
So it's not going to be solely specific to the tissue right there that is directly needing to grow.
If they're circulating to ourselves in the area, which there always is, you're basically adding gasoline to the fire of a circulated to yourself. Now you have to weigh out the risk benefit reward package when you make a decision to have surgery.
Well, I'm going to weigh that out and it's better to remove that tumor. I think that's going to be my best interest that I'm going to have to deal with, you know, using maybe some nutraceuticals to to slow down mTOR. So I don't just spill insulin growth factor on to circulated tumor cells.
So it's a natural process for growth to take place and for replication to take place, but you're going to see through this that there's all these processes that we're exposed to from exogenous sources that are stimulating that pathway.
These are reasons why we see increased cancer rates today. So people ask, well, good to say, when the war on cancer started in 1971, their incidence of cancer in the United States was 1 in 21. Now it's 1 in 2.5. What the hack is going on.
If this is a war, we are losing horribly. Well, this is what we're looking at. So EMF's and cell phone towers stimulate, especially if you have this gene defects. So if you're person that I already went over your genetics and you don't remember me talking about this.
And I said to you, your copy of the 23 and me, this gene is down at the bottom of your copy of the 23 and me. And there's four genes in this CAC and a one C family. And if you have defects in that gene, you're much more susceptible to EMF's.
From dirty electricity in your house, to cell phones, to cell phone towers, to high wire lines, there's EMF's going through us all the time. If you have defects of that gene, you're more susceptible for those to be producing an increase really insulin and glucose levels, but high insulin levels. And that stimulates and tore production.
High fructose corn syrup stimulates this stimulates and tore production. But there's one pathway that I really wanted to talk about today, and it's this one.
So MSG, modusody and glutamate.
So exogenous glutamates in our food.
Glutamine and bone broth.
So if you're a natural thinking person and you are looking at Facebook and you are searching the sites of what to do for healing your body, you probably come across some of these things here.
MSG is modusody and glutamate and you probably read that that's not good for you.
Now modusody and glutamate is only one of about 25 different forms of glutamate that are purposely put in foods.
So why would they personally put purposely put them in foods because glutamate is a natural substance, but it can be synthesized in a laboratory.
And they would purposely put it in foods because glutamate is a stimulatory substance to your brain.
So it's a stimulatory neurotransmitter.
So it stimulates your brain. You need glutamate in your brain. You need it.
And what glutamate does is it wakes you up and you are awake and you are alert and you are your brain is revved up and you pushes your brain into a high beta wave.
You have four different types of waves in your brain. A beta state of your brain is in a state of hyper-learning.
And there can be benefits to glutamate. They can be helpful. So there's a whole bunch of different genes that affect glutamate.
You need to get it out of your brain, converting to gamma, which is a colony neurotransmitter, or genes that produce excess glutamate.
So this has any of those genes. And here's just two of them. GAD, the GAD-1 and GAD-2 genes, the DAO genes help you expel glutamates and break them down into gamma.
But there's a whole bunch of GLU-D genes, a whole bunch of different genes that will cause a person, if they have defects in those genes, will cause a person to have up-regulated glutamate levels.
Even if you ate this perfect diet and you never were exposed to glutamates exogenously in your diet, you could still have genetic expression that you make way too much glutamate.
And glutamate is made in your body through glutamate. So glutamate is a libido acid. Glutamate is a neurotransmitter.
So glutamate is a libido acid, where are libido acids found, but it proteins. So if you eat any proteins, it has glutamate in it, and it will break down it to glutamate in your body.
So glutamate breaks down to glutamate in your body. So if I have certain genes that I readily break down glutamate to glutamate, I mean quite quickly break down all my glutamate to glutamate.
And if I have other genes, I don't get rid of glutamate, so I have all this excess glutamate, so that I'm in this category with all this excess glutamate.
And I could have some symptoms like anxiety, OCD issues. Perseverated, thought, difficult to let things go.
You know, hard to fall asleep. Sometimes don't tend to get restful sleep.
The positive of having a lot of glutamate is those people are going to do well in school. They're going to be pretty smart. Their mind goes a mile a minute.
So there's some pros and cons, right. The big negative of glutamate is they're going to have a highly upregulated, um, M-tore pathway.
And the people with high glutamate levels have proven time and again, have a much higher increase risk of cancer.
And if they have cancer and they fit into this pathway, then we have to take more progressive movements to try to lower their glutamate levels.
So this is one of the pieces that we look at when we look at person's genes to determine the diet that they're on.
But in truth, it would be good for most people to reduce glutamate levels.
It would really be important for all people to reduce glutamate levels. Matter of fact, what do my colleagues wrote a book about glutamate levels and the braid not really talking.
I don't know. Anywhere he talks about cancer in the book. He's mainly talking about the risk of Alzheimer's early dementia as of all sorts.
And autoimmune issues in the braid, ADD, ADHD, it all sorts of mood disorders. And that book was called Excitotoxins. Very good book highly recommend it.
But so glutamate is again, not always a bad guy, but really almost always a bad guy because it's the excess of glutamate that's the problem.
There's not a whole lot of people that have too little glutamate. So it's it's the excess that's the problem because there's so much exogenous glutamate in our food sources.
So when you hear that bone broth is so good to heal your gut, there's a whole bunch of bone broth products on the market. Well, bone broth, the reason why bone broth heals your gut is because the glutamate stimulates the amctor pathway everywhere it's going to touch.
So it's going to be in your gut and it's going to stimulate gut healing. The problem is you're going to absorb an enormous amount of that, especially if you have damaged gut, like leaky gut.
And you're going to have all this glutamate and glutamine going into your gut and earth through the gut wall, and you're going to have a whole bunch of problems because then you're going to have high glutamate levels in the brain.
So what I used to see a lot of ADD, ADHD kids years ago, one of the biggest things was you decreased the inflammation of the brain. So if you have friends and family that have that type of issue or early dementia issues and Alzheimer's reducing glutamate levels should be key number one in trying to help heal that person.
So again, where would you get the exogenous glutamates like the MSG and the 25 other types of glutamates that they put in food.
Anything that, you know, now with the last presidential administration passed a law that they don't have to be listed in foods.
So they're listed as natural and artificial favorites.
Well, that's just about everything. Yeah, well, salary doesn't happen in there. So that's good.
So anything that's going to be boxed or packaged, you know, that doesn't say organic, no MSG.
They're still not even a guarantee, even if it says no MSG that it doesn't have other forms of glutamate.
So it's very frustrating. So it's hard to know. So again, like shopping the outer edge of the grocery store is always best where there's fresh and frozen foods instead of boxed and packaged.
And that glutamate would be going on if glutamate is we determine is really a made feeder of a person's cancer going out a low protein low glutamate diet.
And bone broth is never a good idea for any cancer patients. So your own bone broth stop using bone broth.
This could also lead to a lot of even worse problems. The DAO, especially the DAO one gene is, you know, if you have a double little defect of that gene, it could lead to a lot of psychotic episodes that you're going to be much more prone to schizophrenia and a medic depression and such.
It's quite serious that you could control it quite well with the diet and doing some other things that will help pull glutamates out of the body.
So it is very manageable. Most of those disorders are extremely manageable, you know, with a lot of success.
But stimulated amtore, what will that do? It stimulates that replication.
Ultimately, understand, amtore, this slide right here is blockied autophagy. So when you're blockied, sell death and sell recycling, well, then we got problems.
So, so though it's healing other cells, it's blocking cell death and that's not good. We'll talk in later episodes about these new genes that have just been published papers on them that these are genes specifically stimulated autophagy.
So they have defects in these genes are much more prone to cancers. Some new genes are just recently discovered some really cool stuff.
And then there's some things that will stimulate. That's one of the things why vitamin D is a huge stimulator of this new articles about burberry coming out.
I was always a big fan of burberry, but no, after this, it's like, boy, maybe I should get everybody at burberry.
So it stimulates this pathway. And I probably make a mistake of, but with most of my patients, the biggest mistake I probably make is not putting about things that maybe would be good for them.
This comes from my problem, my mental block edge of I don't like to take a lot of stuff or I just don't remember two. So I don't think I think nobody likes to. So if you're on this call or you're listening to this later and if you're not on vitamin D at burberry, you know, you probably should be.
We have a product called clear burberry. And you probably have my idea already.
So these are the pathways that we want to look at over the next coming weeks. Here's another picture of glutamated. This is the gene that we talk another gene. We talk about big and our glutamate pathway, because this is the gene that brings glutamate inside the cell.
And that this gene is what stimulates amtore. So through glutamate, it's direct stimulation at amtore, amtore, this way also Lucid, which I didn't discuss in this talk very much yet.
Lucid is another amino acid found in proteins, stimulates amtore through the ring pathway, again, same thing.
Glutamate, glutamate that enters the cell, this picture doesn't show glutamate entering the cell, but glutamate converts to glutamate.
So people with defects in these genes accelerates that conversion and same thing with glue to alpha ketoglutarate, which stimulates amtore.
So it can be a bad guy, but it shouldn't be a bad guy if we don't have so much glutamate, you know, and so many glutamates. Well, the problem is again, you know, I believe that you think, okay, where are we as a human race created to eat meat?
Well, I think yes, we were, maybe initially if you believe in the creation that we were initially put in the garden and we weren't eating meat at all, but it's certainly from a biblical standpoint is okay for us to eat meat.
However, you look at even from a biblical times, I mean, how often did they eat meat? I mean, if they brought the best of their their animals for sacrifice and most of the people could only bring a dove that tells you they didn't have very much meat.
So what was it, you know, it's only in this these last few generations, these last few hundred years that we've experienced the ability to eat meat for breakfast lunch and dinner, if you really look at historical dietary measures and how we eat at least I look back at it and some people might argue that.
But I think we eat way too much glutamate and I'm not I do eat meat, so I'm not a vegan, but you could you could cast an argument for us, maybe consuming too much glutamate and glutamates were never exogenous in our food sources.
And again, the reason why they put glutamates is because they're excitatory and it makes you want to eat more.
So like nacho cheese Doritoships have four different glutamates in them and the whole purpose is so that you go, wow, these are good your brain does that.
So it stimulates your brain glutamate pathways and it's addictive.
So glutamate is your addictive cycle. That's why we have so many addicts of drugs and alcohol and everything else is because it stimulates glutamate.
So just more reasons to watch your glutamate. So it increases is empty or anything that's going to increase emptor is going to decrease cell death.
So that's what this is all about.
So cancer diets should limit glutamate lucid arginine.
We really talk about arginine but it's the same thing on here.
It should limit that, you know, regardless of whether you're going completely done, you know, protein or not, you're lower your protein levels. That's why most every person that's my patient I decreased their meat consumption.
And how decreased should I get? Well, how decreased can you get really is the question you ask yourself and you work at that.
Here's some sources of arginine and lucid I was going to put glutamated here, but that's, you know, almost everything. So.
But it's protein. That's what it is. So it's not really a secret about that.
All right. Is that bring up any questions? Yes, no.
It's just a lot to take in.
It's a lot to take in. So, but one of the questions that I'll answer here that was said to me is, is this mean that you can have protein powders.
Yes, it does. So this means you, if you're, if you're trying to eliminate glutamate and other proteins. Yeah, you're getting them in a protein powder. Yes, you can't.
So you do have to look at that. The issues that we have with this is that people will say, OK, if I'm trying to eliminate my sugar, so try to eliminate my carbs and get those down.
And now you're saying I should eliminate proteins and get those down. What in the world do I eat?
And that's a very good question. And the answer to that question is number one thing you're eating is your eating vegetables and you're eating.
It's just so foreign to most of our diet that it's difficult to adhere to.
You know, we built our relationships around food and not only with us in the food, but with our families and food.
And we sit down at a table. That's where we have certain relationships. We have everybody over for supper.
And it is very difficult to adhere to a diet when nobody else is adhered to a diet. So I always highly suggest you try to do this as a family, try to eat better as a family.
Just because one person has a diagnosis doesn't mean that other people could eat poorly.
So, but everybody's going to make their own decisions there. But as far as what can you eat? You're eating a lot of vegetables. You're eating some fruits that are going to be lower glycemic index.
And you can eat some protein. You're just looking at, OK, what if I counted by grams of protein? It's just like your carbs. If you start counting your grams of carbs, you'll notice that you're probably at like 200 grams a day.
And then you go, OK, well, what if I dropped that to 100? Could I do that? Yes, I could. Then you go, could I drop that to 50? Could I drop that to 20? 20 would be pretty low. But you could do that. That would be a more ketogenic diet.
But if you're eating a mixed diet and you're dropping your grams of carbs to 50, it's the same thing with your protein. Let's count my grams of protein that I'm eating in a daily basis.
And then let's go, OK, where can I cut that down? Now, if you're not very left brain, and you're like, this is just hurt my brain even thinking about this, you can't just look at the amount of protein you're eating.
So, normally I eat two hamburgers. Could you live with just one for a while? Normally, I eat a chicken breast. Could you cut it in half and put the other in the fridge? You can have it tomorrow.
If you just start cutting things in half and see how you do with that, OK, I put some chicken on my salad. Do you need chicken on your salad? Oh, I guess I don't need it. So you start doing that. And then, and then you start, you know, look at it.
Look at it that way, then you could possibly have a treat where you could go off of it to have hamburger that day. So normally, when I put a person on a purposefully low glutamate, low-methylated low-protein diet, I have to go five days on two days off.
So it gives them a break, and it's not like this is a lifestyle that they just hate.
So, hopefully that helps a little bit. And sometimes that helps if you just play with your diet like that, so it doesn't feel like a torture chamber that you're subject to yourself to.
Dr. Connor, where do eggs fall in?
So eggs have protein in it. So eggs have coli that is really good for you. Eggs have other nutrients that are good for you too. So,
eggs may be a choice, my choice of protein today, but it just goes to, you know, do I have to eat protein, you know, how much protein do I have to eat at every meal?
Can I have a meal where it's just salad and it's no protein really in it.
Can I, okay, if I get to eat protein at every meal, can I cut it in half the amount of protein that is.
So, and eat more vegetables. So, most people, you look at the typical American breakfast. I mean, it's all carbs and protein.
That's all it is. There's, you know, and sometimes not very good fats.
But even though protein is going to be in vegetables and carbs are going to be in vegetables, but typical carb in an American breakfast is a bad carb.
So, they're eating pancakes or waffles or toast or something and syrup.
And it, which is not a good complex car, and then they're eating a protein like make it or sausage, which is a horrible source of protein.
So, maybe I could eat eggs cooked in coconut oil and, and or two egg oblate with a bunch of vegetables cooked in coconut oil or an egg, one egg cooked in coconut oil with sauteed vegetables, sweathered over the top of the egg.
But our later talks, we're going to talk about, because we're running out time here, but we're going to talk about fasting and intermittent fasting as a way to put yourself in a state of your body in a state of more ketosis without severely restricted your diet.
In a way that you're going to a full ketogenic diet. So, we'll talk about that. So, do I need three meals a day is, is the next comment that will lead into that. So, just help a little bit.
Understand why we want to look at this pathway and how to make this pathway make more sense and looks real complicated. But when we break it out into pieces, it's really not.
And why sometimes I recommend nutrition, why I sometimes take nutrition away from people, you know, that, oh, no, you can't take this because it's got too much glutamate, it's got the diet eaten, methyl donors don't we're not going to do that because it's going to stimulate that pathway.
If any other questions, we will end today's call and I'll get this up on our Facebook page on ASAP. Thanks so much.